well my job is a predominantly a feature
film editor is to first of all read the
script that the director is intending to
make and see if there's anything in
there that I want to pass on calm him
wise as far as how it reads and then
basically be there for the entire time
of the shoot and again you know it's
it's basically my responsibility to keep
up with the camera make sure that you're
editing each sequence as best as you can
I mean everything's shot out of order
but you do what you can make sure it
makes sense and make sure you've got the
coverage to do whatever you might want
to do with it because obviously on a
feature film it's very expensive on a
day-by-day shooting basis and if there's
something missing you better put your
hand up or it's you know half a million
dollar problem well basically I'm on
before the camera starts rolling I'm not
on during pre-production but I do have
been put into the script but then I'm on
through full production full shoot all
the way through posts basically until we
release not necessarily release the film
but we have all the contractual
obligations fulfilled for a complete
film so on a feature film you're on it
for about a year in time well I think
when you're offered a job it is some
you've got to be very careful when
you're in in the interview especially if
you're working with someone new because
you are going to be spending an
incredible amount of time with them and
it's it can be a very intense period
specifically post-production so if
you've got any feeling that you're not
going to get on with this person or
you're not in any way like-minded I
would recommend running away because
otherwise you've got a year oh hell if
that's not the case and during that
period you you realize that you're both
like-minded I normally find when I'm
meeting someone you are about to work
with someone you as you talk about
movies not necessarily the movie you're
going to work on
but the movies you love and without
exception you know as you listen to the
director talk and they listen to me
talking if you're all kind of on the
same page with what you love and what
you like and what turns you on about
movies you know you're gonna get on and
if they're talking about films that you
can't stand you know you're not so it's
a good idea to be convinced that you're
in sync I want a better for one of a
better term with the way everyone's
looking at the project because I think
being an editor you're being cast as an
editor as you would cast a composer or
cast a cinematographer or in fact cast
an actor
it's you've got to fit in with the
overall picture otherwise those working
parts are not going to come together
well I think it's just the relationship
you build over several pictures when you
start you're testing each other's views
on you know what works and what doesn't
and making adjustments to suit so the
beauty of a long-term relationship with
a director is that it becomes and with
any other head of department or crew
member is there becomes a shorthand and
and they expected performance thing that
you on a new film meeting new people you
know you're forever having to explain
again the process of what how you like
it and how you think it should go and I
think that's why there are such
long-term relationships formed because
that's time and that's time you could be
putting into the film yeah we work
together well I mean I just think we
like the same thing so if I'm liking
what I'm doing I'm very convinced that
he's gonna like it when he sees it or
she's gonna like it when she sees it
depending on who you're working with and
if that wasn't the case again you've
been miscast or or you're not a good fit
with that particular director so I never
second-guess what I'm doing because I
think that's the other thing that can go
wrong it's like I'm not doing it to
please someone else but by doing it to
please me it's pleasing them
and again that's just built up over you
know a long a long-term relationship I
think when I first read Chris's draft of
Dunkirk it was scary and exhilarating
because normally he's a heavily dialogue
oriented scriptwriter
so you were always pushing the narrative
forward through dialogue
whereas Dunkirk was very very little
exposition and it was going to be a very
visual film and and the visual
storytelling you know is what was going
to make this film worth watching and of
course you layer on top of that the
intersecting timelines which Chris loves
to play with time you get this kind of
war movie like no other which is not
reliant on you know carnage and blood in
the camera and all that kind of thing
it's relying on a level of suspense that
Chris said early that he wanted to
maintain he wanted to run this feeling
of your heart beating away right from
the first frame of image you're starting
to get tense and that first gunshot
you're tense pretty well all the way
through the movie and it was very
experimental when I read the script I
was thinking this could be a hundred
million dollar art movie and probably be
the end of all of us but thankfully it
wasn't the land air and sea concept was
built into the script but of course when
you're in post-production and editing
where those points changed and converged
and where you allowed the audience in on
the multiple timeline gags were all
controllable so we spent a lot of time
perfecting where we moved from land to
air to sea and back again may probably
in the first construction it was quite
confusing because a lot of times you
went back and you've been away from one
of the components for too long a period
so you be sort of thinking I'm not sure
where I am or what's happening
and then it was just a matter of
continuous processing to get it to the
point where we felt the audience could
sit through this reasonably complicated
pathway still enjoy it and even if a few
of them didn't quite catch what was
happening they'll catch up with it
good confusion versus bad confusion so
that was something that you know we
tested and tested and tested amongst
ourselves and with some close friends
who weren't related to the film we did a
lot of screenings of Dunkirk until we
thought we had it exactly where we
needed it
well weeks we'd screen every Friday to
ourselves and maybe a couple of people
who hadn't seen the film just as in my
editing room just as a matter of process
and every Friday we would have developed
new ideas and changed the structure and
it was interesting because you'd see
improvements at a couple of screenings
and then we try something you'd see a
complete we'd look at one other and go
you know we can't turn the film off we
know it's not working but we'll let it
run because the poor people who've come
to look at it haven't seen it before but
and they were never harsh on us but we
could tell that the the move that we did
had damaged the emotional side of the
film or the ability for you to follow it
and it was surprising how with a few
small changes you could derail this film
and with a few small changes you could
lock it into a much stronger path well I
always cut you know and produce the
sound as I'm going and but interestingly
on this one we cut it more like a silent
film in the first pass because we had
our IMAX cameras are basically extremely
noisy which is quite distracting if
you're editing between music sound and
visual effects where Andrew Jackson from
double- which is based here in England
he was doing all of the visual effects
which are which basically you can't see
them in the film and you shouldn't see
them the film was very heavily shotting
camera but the visual effects are
actually beautifully handled because of
that like where you'd normally put a CG
plane in the sky we comp in an actual
plane that was from another shot we'd
never let them use CG elements and so
99.8% of this film is 100% practical and
comped very carefully together so we're
working with him because we're
developing that the whole time and
unlike most other films made when we
were at week 10 of the director's cut we
mixed did a temp mix on the film and
then we projected it for the studio on
70 millimeter with all of the visual
effects in the movie so to the studios I
they're watching a completely finished
film and and we kind of that's a thing
that Kris sort of imposes upon everybody
which is when we do that first studio
screening it looks like a finished movie
but the fact that we screened it on 70
millimeter I think is I doubt there's
ever been a film made that did a and
work print 70 mil screening with a mix
at that point which was very cool looked
amazing I think the biggest challenge
editing this film was just one of
keeping it accessible to the audience
and keeping the audience with us and not
making it so complicated that people
just gave up and and got confused with
what they were looking at and just
keeping the tension level up and and
keeping the exact point of the emotional
release when the little ships showed up
with Kenneth Branagh that was a really
critical moment because if we moved it
slightly earlier or later in the
timeline you didn't get the emotional
rush that you did when it was in its
exact position and we tested that
numerous times because we were trying to
pull it forward and trying to push it
back and it just found its natural place
that was a big challenge and I think
just you know keeping true to the
reality of the situation
raishin and not letting you know not
letting it be inundated with CG
enhancements was the other challenge of
you know not doing shots with 10,000
little ships coming at you because
that's not what happened so you know
trying to keep it much more real and I
think the audience know that I think
inherently when you watch your film and
you see a shot and you just know it's
been loaded you kind of will I do anyway
I sort of go yeah right a million ships
on the horizon it's like what all at the
same time I don't think so so anyway
that was a challenge but aside from that
it was just you know an exhilarating
film to work on so it was cool
[Music]